what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey screw trailer
reactions and other YouTube videos we're
gonna become the real BTS channel that's
where we're headed today's topper war to
your video requests comes from none
other than the hottie from eyerly and
that is worth natalie Doran we're gonna
watch dope this is a song from from like
four years ago
one of the songs that helped launch them
to fame oh look out now we're gonna see
where it all took off video only has 513
million views what much losers before we
go into this though I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us over at our patreon page we
do weekly Q&A is over there and we do I
don't believe in retakes a TV show
reactions stream alongs
sync up some shows have reaction
highlights included ten minutes worth of
the show and also homeboy here does
music video coverage weekly oftentimes
it is kpop BTS related I might make a
cameo who knows check out our patreon
page today let's get into this
I decided from now on your Greg monster
and I'm John Cooke cool so it's great oh
no it's not no not by a long shot
[Music]
damn work man you drenched when I sleep
yeah
snores prove it all even our youth rots
in the studio
[Music]
I reject rejection mom always over this
up but you accept really inject why were
the BTS guys do you all work
[Music]
[Music]
I uh like one shot yeah Adele video
[Music]
it's a sack move a little dance central
and teach me that oh yeah dude there's
got it should bring back Dance Central
in a full-on BTS edition just only BTS
songs you could learn all the dances and
then we can switch transition and just
be a kpop tutorial dance channel like
we've always wanted to be improv improv
but this was a pretty dope music video
ah DUP don't you say don't know ropes up
yeah this was a dope music video I love
these kind of lyrics man talked a lot
about sacrifice you know they gotta give
up to go up while you're at the club um
you know in the studio working sweating
my assets not what I was not know if you
just if you just learned not to
interrupt once in a while Jon you'd let
me get to my point what was I talking
about are you talking about they even
have their youth rots in the studio I
think it's such a cool line you think
about a lot of those people who are like
ah you got plenty of time you're still
young you're still young you know but
that I've heard people talk about if you
want the things other people don't have
you got to be willing to do the things
other people aren't willing to do it a
lot of times that starts at a young age
work hard now so you could have all the
luxuries when you're older a lot of
times people look back at their youth
feeling like I wish I have put all that
labor in that I putting in now in my
late 20s
sometimes mid forties sometime later and
they did it all at the age of 10 years
old if I'm not mistaken pulled
themselves at school learning at a dance
that's not an accurate fact at all the
level of success they have gathered from
sacrificing what most people their age
would be doing whatever they've
practiced in private they have greatly
reaped the rewards in public yeah and
then some
yes um or improv
apparently that our attitude is kind of
an anomaly for the kpop landscape as I
learned in the comments section of our
previous bangtan dinner party video I do
you appreciate the amount of
perseverance that comes through and yeah
this is a very specific sentiment on
that wavelength you know there are a lot
of songs that hit hard and are about you
know your hustle and you know the amount
of work you're willing to do over your
competition but there's something about
it coming from BTS that always rings
especially genuine to me even when they
are being braggadocious you know saying
I think I'm kind of dope that's
sentiment and you know that sort of
braggadocio style is rife in pop and
hip-hop and all sort of stuff but for
some reason yeah just seeing like the
glimpses we get into their life into
their actual you know preparation and
the work they've done over the years
like I really believe that they've
earned the lyrics when they're singing
about yes it's different when they talk
about it because they have a thing that
I think is so important to factor in
when you hear advice from anyone which
is called track record clearly they've
proven themselves and with that level of
proof they can say these kind of things
you know I love that line of their
uttered a couple times I reject
rejection of a big part of what I've
learned about dealing with success and
any endeavor is learning how to deal
with failure and learning how to deal
with rejection specifically I think
especially in the entertainment industry
where you're constantly creating and
then you're trying to sell it or make
money off of it or go to the next level
there's a lot of levels of rejection and
honing in on your own self-worth despite
what others are saying about you I think
is a big theme especially to everything
that are talking about here and then
yeah going towards all the interviews
we've seen as of late watching those
interviews of them hearing these songs
you're like oh this is just a reflection
of who they really are just the coolest
style you can think of you know with the
utmost performative confidence and I
mean the video end of this too was
impressive again partly because yeah all
these long shots you have I kept sitting
there wondering how they
I don't know exactly how you stitch
together one of these long shots that
has these speed ramps and zooms in After
Effects since we effects right I'm not
sure that's the thing as I've seen the
corner crew guys do that that kind of
camera motion yeah yeah yeah still video
yeah I feel like that's the only way you
could properly get I mean I'm sure there
are other ways to get of course in
camera well that's a non post you can
definitely do it especially because they
do it so often they have such high
production value that I wouldn't be
altogether surprised if they found a way
to do most of this in camera one takes
or you know several one takes yeah this
is like the first band where
consistently I'm sort of like if there
was a behind-the-scenes featurette just
sort of shove the production of one of
these videos I would be very curious to
see that and I also feel like RM talking
about you know and welcome it's your
first time to BTS yeah I feel like this
would be a great first time to BTS song
actually yeah yeah that encrypted it's
croats it's all the way I must have the
name that song
that's how I'll always remember it you
know it's called fake love I can't call
someone CRO tits and once they're just
trying to be someone else yeah don't be
a protest yeah man you know a while
don't be a be a crow tip but just be a
crow Ted maybe if you see somebody just
being themselves then you can say like
hey you're a crow tip man you're not
trying to be a stork or nothing as per
this one specific example I wrote it's
Croton all right well this was great
this is great speaking of crow tits
Thank You Natalie for sending this our
way my dear I hope your vacation you
just had with your friends is fun saw
you posting on Instagram getting genuine
just putting more jackets on pants long
pants what are you talking about she
posted her first nudes
oh that's dude ice cream sauce why do
you mean she's plotting nice
screenshotted that's not true she did
not pose nude I want everyone to know
that she posed nude for him oh that was
a blight didn't anybody tell me I hacked
your Instagram last no I'm sorry I
messed up I mean I don't know I guess
that's probably better in the long run
what is going on John we got a video to
film Natalie
consider that your shoutout you know the
battery with all of our heart I treasure
you with my entire being it's true
all that blood flow that leaves his
brain and goes to another body part just
for you my legs and arms for
coordination teachers from Ireland that
doesn't count out there hey guys what's
your favorite BTS song subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell check us on patreon we got all them
goodies SIA
you